the moment when disaster struck
for the people of this community time suddenly
stopped for them their world of peace and order
was suddenly brought to an end a disaster does not
restrict itself to any particular time or place
it may come in the dead of night it
may come at dawn at midday or at dusk
no one particular season is disasters alive or
disaster lurks behind the smiling face of summer
and grips the winter plains with snow and despair
in the great timberlands of the far west disaster
dons a robe of licking flames disaster stalks
the prairies as a sinister cloud of whirling
dust or demolishes the waterfront of a huge
city
or nature on the rampage
disaster can occur anytime
anywhere appearing in the swiftness of a moment
striking with the impact of calamity upon people
upon property leaving in its wake a toll
of staggering destruction and human misery
go down the disaster roll of recent years
vicksburg mississippi flint michigan
waco texas worcester massachusetts and even the
nation's capital in each of these cities municipal
services were unable to cope with the sudden
tremendous demands imposed by a major disaster
then every man woman and child trained or
untrained had to pitch in and help to reduce
the toll of death and loss even avert the very
course of disaster and so this lesson was learned
a community unprepared for major disaster will
suffer the greatest loss but in a community with
a civil defense plan ready to be put into action
at a moment's notice man can rest from disaster
a part of the toll it would normally take
realizing this most states and territories
have designated the state civil defense
office as the coordinating disaster agency
this is the town a community with a civil defense
plan to meet a major disaster the time is anytime
the place anywhere in the united states and the
courthouse building is the office of the local
civil defense director at his disposal are
volunteers some with civil defense training
he knows the location of needed equipment
and supplies he knows that in the event
of major disaster he and his state can call
on the federal civil defense administration
for financial aid and the help of other
federal agencies meanwhile time ticks away days
weeks years disaster may never come
but if it does this community is
prepared
hey
the local civil defense headquarters or
the control center become the focal point
in a great mass effort by all
organized groups and volunteers
near the site of this major disaster
volunteers help root traffic
within the area workers trained and rescued
are already engaged in search for survivors
so
here the city firemen battle the flames assisted
by trained civil defense auxiliary firefighters
meanwhile other skilled volunteers enrolled in
the engineering service are busy removing wreckage
while heavy equipment aids in clearing a path
to casualties trapped in demolished buildings
equipment from federal stockpiles
begins to appear on the scene
many normal communication facilities
have been temporarily knocked out
but walkie-talkies are manned by civil defense
trained volunteers stationed at disaster points
throughout the city while others work at
communications centers or as messengers
survivors receive first aid treatment while
the more seriously injured are removed to a
hospital where facilities are provided to meet
the emergency here in this major disaster the
federal stockpile of emergency medical
supplies and equipment is made available
providing emergency care for disaster sufferers is
a responsibility of the american red cross which
sets up registration and information services and
provides victims with food shelter and clothing
and emergency medical assistance in short a
smooth functioning disaster operation utilizing
all available manpower and facilities
to help rest from the forces of natural
or wartime disaster part of the normal
toll
this time of disaster all of us hope never
comes but should this disaster ever strike
our chances of survival will be all the greater
through civil defense training and preparation
disaster man-made or nature on the rampage
too often the lesson is learned too late in
a community unprepared disaster will take its
full toll catastrophe must be met head on civil
defense is our best hope against a time we pray
may never come but a time that could
be tomorrow the time of disaster